ja was genau hat da may zum Sieg
verholfen warum hat er so klar
gewonnen ich denke dass es neben may
zwei weitere ganz große Gewinner gibt
nämlich Wut und Frustration über das
bisherige politische Establishment in
Argentinien so gut wie alle Menschen mit
denen wir in Buenos Aires und Umgebung
gesprochen haben die mleay unterstützen
haben gesagt dass sie sehr wütend sind
sehr enttäuscht sind von der Politik von
diesem Staat dass sie jegliches
Vertrauen verloren haben dass die
Politik Ihnen eine bessere sichere
Zukunft gewährleisten kann und
gewissermaßen kann man das auch
verstehen wenn man sich die Zahlen
anschaut denn argentinien ist seit
Jahrzehnten einer Wirtschafts
dauerwirtschaftskrise von einer Krise
zur nächsten geht es aus der Inflation
kommen sie nicht raus sie ist bei über
140% inzwischen mehr als 40% also fast
die Hälfte der argentinia lebt unterhalb
der Armutsgrenze und all das in einem
Land was mal das reichste Südamerika
eines der reichsten der Welt war und das
sorgt für diesen großen Frust und genau
darauf hat eben mele auch angespielt
immer wieder im Wahlkampf er ist einfach
auch aufgefallen als ganz anders mit
seinen Auftritten mit dem wirren Haar
dass er wirklich kultiviert worüber er
auch immer wieder spricht mit seinen Wut
Anfällen im Fernsehen wo er schon mal
ein Modell der Zentralbank zertrümmert
und immer wieder die Kettensäge mit der
durch die Straßen und die Städte gezogen
ist mit denen er mit der er diesen
überbordenen Sozialstaat diesen Staat
zersägen will das Motto ist gewesen
Hauptsache anders schlimmer kann es
nicht werden und ich denke das hat viele
dazu bewegt may zu wählen m hat also
viel versprochen aber ist eben auch ein
totaler politikneuling also was ist
jetzt an Änderung auch zu erwarten
tatsächlich ja das ist die große Frage
die sich natürlich heute am Morgen
danach ganz Argentinien stellt wenn man
in argentinischen Medien liest und hört
kommt immer wieder der Begriff vom
freiluftlabor Argentinien vom großen
Experiment denn keiner weiß so richtig
genau was mele eigentlich will wofür er
wirklich steht er hat versprochen Dinge
wie Zentralbank abschaffen zahil der
Ministerien mehr als halbieren den
Sozialstaat drastisch verschlangen und
vor allem den Dollar einzuführen um den
inflationsgeplagten Peso abzulösen aber
für all das braucht er eben auch
Verbündete der argentinische Präsident
ist nicht so mächtig dass er das alleine
machen kann und daran hapert es noch
meleay hat keinerlei Erfahrung als
Führungsperson in der Politik er hatte
kein amtfeuer inne seine Partei ist
winzig selbst das rechtsbündnis was sich
jetzt beginnt um ihn zu scharen selbst
das hat noch keine Mehrheit im Parlament
und deswegen wird es sehr sehr schwierig
zu schauen was er tatsächlich umsetzen
kann und ob er diese Erwartungen einfach
alles andere und damit in der
Wahrnehmung vieler Wähler besser zu
machen ob er diese Erwartung wirklich
erfüllen kann das ist jetzt die große
Frage die jetzt Argentinien bevorsteht
Einordnung von unserem
argentinienkorrespondenten Christoph
röckerat vielen Dank